Welcome to Bible Answers Live, where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions.
Let's face it. It's not always easy to
understand everything you read in the
Bible. With 66 books and more than
700,000 words, the Bible can generate a
lot of questions. If you'd like answers
to your Bible questions, you've come to
the right place. Now, here's your host,
Pastor Doug Batchelor, president and
speaker of Amazing Facts.
Hello, listening friends. Would you like
to hear an amazing fact?
For about 500 years, the Roman Empire
was the undisputed military powerhouse
that conquered most of the Western
world. This was due in part to their
heavy investment in their military and
war machines.
Today, there are about 195 countries in
the world, and most spend something for
their military budget.
But of all these countries, the United
States of America spends the most,
taking up to 42% of the world's military
expenditures.
In other words, almost half of the
world's military investment is made by
one country. In fact, if you added up
all the military budgets of Europe,
China, Russia, Japan, the Middle East,
Australia, East Asia, and Latin America,
you'd still have a sum less than what
the United States alone spends on its
armed forces.
For example, just in 2016, the United
States spent 611
billion dollars in the military, whereas
the country in second place, China,
spent only 215 billion.
No wonder the United States remains by
far the most powerfully armed nation on
Earth and the world's only real military
superpower.
You know, the book of Revelation in
chapter 13 identifies two beasts in the
last days that will try to compel
uniform international worship. And it
will certainly require a large military
power to enforce this.
Did you know the Bible also foretells an
escalation of war will be one of the
signs of the last days? Stay with us,
friends. We're going to learn more as
Amazing Facts brings you this edition of
Bible Answers Live.
You're listening to Bible Answers Live,
honest answers to your Bible questions.
Our phone lines are now open. If you
have a Bible-related question, call us
at 1-800-God-Says.
That's 1-800-463-7297.
Now, let's join our host, Pastor Doug
Batchelor, and our co-host, Pastor Shawn
Ross.
Welcome, friend. Lines are open. This is
Bible Answers Live, and if you have a
Bible question for the next hour, we're
going to do our best to search the word
with you and find the answers.
The promise is, if you seek, you'll
find, and that's what we're going to do.
Lines are open. If you call now, good
chance you'll get your question on
tonight's program.
And that number once again is
800-God-Says.
That is 800-463-7297. It's a free phone
call, of course,
in North America.
800- 463-7297.
We invite any question regarding the
Bible or living the Christian life. We
don't talk about romance or finance, but
we talk about the word of God and how to
live forever. One more time, 800-
463-7297.
I'm Doug Batchelor. My name is Shawn
Ross. Good evening, listening friends.
And Pastor Doug, as we always do, let's
start the program with prayer. Dear
Father, we thank you that we have this
opportunity to open up the word and
study together. And Lord, we pray that
the Holy Spirit would guide us as we
search for truth, for you have promised
that if we seek, we shall find. Pray for
your leading. Be with those listening,
wherever they might be. And lead us to
clearly understand the scriptures, for
we ask this in Jesus' name. Amen. Amen.
Well, you know, Pastor Doug, you can't
help but notice the amount of um
discussion in the current media with
reference to military build-up and uh
uh various weapons of war and the
potential for outbreak of war, even
nuclear war with everything happening
right nowadays.
And uh you were reading in your text
that probably uh there's never been a
time when the United States and uh some
of the other countries in the world,
they've been so armed and so prepared
for just a massive conflict. It's been
many years since World War II. Mhm. And
in the meantime, there's been a
stockpile of weapons, so it's almost as
if we're facing some kind of Armageddon.
You know, at the end of World War II,
Douglas MacArthur, following the signing
of surrender by Japan,
he made a statement, and he said um we
have had our last chance. If we do not
devise some greater and more equitable
system, Armageddon will be at our door.
I mean, he saw the the horrors of what
happened with World War II. And of
course, America did use nuclear weapons
back then, or atomic, I should say,
weapons in Japan.
And um you know, now there's an awful
lot of sword or saber-rattling, as they
say, between
Iran and North Korea and Russia, and the
news is filled with, you know, tension
between the nations.
And Jesus foretold in Matthew 24,
speaking of his return and the end of
the world, he said, "You'll hear of wars
and rumors of wars." We certainly have
that right now in the news every day.
"See that you are not troubled." He
said, "This is normal. This is going to
happen.
For all these things must come to pass.
But the end is not yet. For nation will
rise against nation and kingdom against
kingdom."
Now, we've certainly seen an escalation
of this in the last days. I mean, just
in the last century, um some of the last
survivors that lived over the time of
World War I. There are still people
walking around in the world today that
were alive during World War I and World
War Not many left.
And we're losing people who actually
fought in World War II. They're all My
dad was one of those. They're kind of
passing off the scene. But uh you think
about that the world involved in war.
Now, what would happen now
with the way weapons have become so
devastatingly accurate? They used to
just carpet bomb back then cuz the
bombs, you know, the if they got within
a football field of their target, they
felt good.
But now, they are you know, laser-guided
and uh you know,
bunker-busting and and infrared night
bombing and stealth bombing, and it's uh
it's just really unimaginable of what
the devastation would be if the nations,
major nations, get involved in releasing
these weapons they've stockpiled. We
hoped after the end of the Cold War,
it would um
settle down.
Now, people are wondering, does this
mean we're at the threshold of what the
Bible calls the battle of Armageddon?
No, friends.
There may be a big battle coming, but it
is not the Bible battle of Armageddon
yet.
That's coming also. And if you'd like to
know, what is the battle of Armageddon?
We have a free offer for you, and you
don't want to miss this one.
It's a book written by Joe Crews, the
founder of Amazing Facts. It is a
classic, and the book is simply called
Armageddon.
And we'll be happy to send it to anybody
who calls and asks. If you want to know
more about what the Bible says with
referencing this great battle of
Armageddon, we will be happy to send
this to anybody who calls. The number to
call for our resource phone line is
800-835-6747.
You can ask for the book called
Armageddon. That number again is
800-835-6747.
And if you have a Bible question, our
phone line here to the studio is
800-463-7297.
That's 800-463-7297.
That'll bring you right here to the
studio with your Bible question. Our
phone lines are open. It's a good time
to pick up your phone and give us a
call.
Our first caller this evening is
Michael, and Michael is listening in
Florida. Michael, welcome to the
program. You're on the air.
Hello, Pastor Doug, Pastor Ross. Good to
speak to you again.
Thank you. Uh good to hear from you. And
your question tonight?
Yes. Um okay, so I hope this question
doesn't come off as uh too odd or
arbitrary, maybe, but at any rate, um I
had once recently heard uh
that
well, I I guess it was implied to me
that billiards, or or the game of pool,
uh is something that I guess not
Christian. Um
Or at least that was that was the
impression that I got. Um it was
particularly from article that I was
reading online that was referencing the
writing of an author I'm pretty sure
you've heard of, uh Ellen White.
Um
where she I believe she mentioned how uh
a Christian would not find themselves in
a place uh that uh they couldn't ask
God's blessing on, such as uh the
theaters, the dance halls, the the pool
halls, the billiard saloons.
Um
and the the thing I'm guess I'm confused
at really is whether or not it was the
actual game of pool, or was it like the
environment of the
billiard hall, perhaps, cuz I know
usually those are like, you know, bars
and stuff like that.
Uh
All right. Well, let me see if I can
dive in. You're I'm going to bring your
volume down a little bit, Michael,
because we're getting the some digital
squeal from your phone or something.
Um
So, what about the game of pool? And is
it uh wrong for Christian to play pool?
Uh you know, especially in the um in the
1800s,
pool halls were almost or the pool
tables were almost exclusively found in
the saloons and the bars filled with
smoke, drinking, and wasn't that good an
environment. It was also true of bowling
back then.
Um when you think about the actual game,
the game of bowling or pool, a game of
physics,
uh it's you know, just a fascinating
game in that respect when you talk about
geometry and
and the physics of it, there's nothing
inherently evil with balls rolling
around a table.
So, statements you might hear from 18th
century authors that talk about that,
probably first and foremost they're
talking about a couple of things. One,
the environment. That was almost always
Uh I think billiards may have become
very popular in France and it was always
in the bars, gambling, betting,
drinking, a lot of thick smoke.
Uh I know I used to go to those places
when my younger days.
Um
but uh
and the other thing with any game
is you for a Christian you've got to ask
yourself, am I being competitive?
Cuz competition you know, can consume a
person and the other is the time. You
know, am I wasting time?
I used to love the game of chess, still
do. Uh I don't play much anymore because
you just have to ask how much time do I
have to put into those things.
So, if a Christian had a pool table in
their house and they were playing a game
of pool, I would not fault that uh
because you know, it's like I said, it's
a game of physics. It's no more evil
than ping-pong
or uh you know, another game where
you're just playing the physics of a
ball.
The other questions you'd ask is the
environment, the amount of time you
spend, and do you get into the
competitive spirit where you know, one
person is
putting down another person or they're
getting it so competitive they get upset
if they lose.
That is generally true with any sports.
But hopefully that answers the question
Michael and that haven't had that
question. Appreciate it.
I thought you were going to ask me about
the scripture that talks about playing
pool. I couldn't find it.
Our next caller is Charles listening
from Alabama. Charles, welcome to the
program.
Hey, how's it going? Good, thanks for
calling.
Okay. Um I had a question for you. Uh it
was basically about incest
and you know, it's we know it's not
right. You know, even science seems to
indicate that, you know, it's not a good
thing to do. And uh you know, in the Old
Testament I believe there might have
been some verses about incest, maybe in
Leviticus.
Um and basically my question was about
God creating the earth in such a manner
with you know, only making two
individuals initially as far as we know,
to where incest would be necessary. And
even after that, you know, I know you
know, Noah and his three sons and their
wives, you know, repopulated the earth.
So, you know, it seems as though incest
would have taken place again. So, that
that's my question.
All right. Well, you know, back in the
days of um
before Noah, in the time of Adam and
Eve, when you think about it, Adam and
Eve had the same
origin, same parents you might say.
Matter of fact, it was even stranger
than that in that Eve came out of Adam.
And uh every other man has come from a
woman except the first woman came from a
man. That's kind of strange.
But um
uh as time went by because of the
problem with genetic vitality being
diminished through inbreeding,
and we all know that whether it's, you
know,
dogs or horses or whatever it is, if
there's too much inbreeding you have all
kinds of genetic mutations that cause
weakness and disease.
Uh and so by the time of Moses is where
you first see the laws that say that a
man was not to marry his his brother.
Now, Abraham married his half sister.
Jacob married his first cousin. Isaac
married his first cousin.
Uh so it wasn't that unusual then, but
then as time goes by,
you know, it's more and more encouraged
to for vitality and health
to stay away from marrying too much
within the family.
As I've traveled around the South
Pacific, uh you know, I've stayed and
visited and minute done ministry in
islands where
you just had a small group of people
living on an island and they would
naturally start to marry pretty close to
the family tree, and they ended up with
all kinds of defects and problems and
genetic um weaknesses because of that.
And there are
there are um certain diseases that
you'll only find for instance among the
Jewish people because um you know, over
the years they've tried to be loyal to
marry other Jewish people,
and if you don't get any outside blood,
you can sometimes have those weaknesses.
Anyway, that's the reason I think that
God especially forbade it and um
you know, uh
yeah, the Lord wants us to uh I
definitely understand why it's wrong,
but I guess my question is more why
would God create it uh like I say, from
the beginning to where it would have to
occur if it's wrong. You know, I feel
like if it's wrong then, it should have
been wrong in the beginning, right? That
doesn't
Well, no, not necessarily because you
know, the reason that it's wrong it
Well, for one thing, in a family, um
brothers ought to be protecting their
sisters, not marrying them.
Uh and um
um
you know, maybe back in the days of Adam
and Eve when there were, you know,
nobody was in the world and people's
genes were perfect, Adam and Eve had
come from the hands of God and they were
eating from the tree of life before they
were driven from the garden, you
wouldn't have that problem. But as time
go by goes by, uh it just wasn't
appropriate.
Yeah, I appreciate that Charles. Good
question.
Next caller is Patricia and she's
listening from Portland, Oregon.
Patricia welcome to the program.
Yes, hi pastors. Um how are you doing
this evening? Good. So, I have a request
first of all, and that would be for
prayer for John Poppy who is homeless
and is in dire need of a place to stay.
So, that's my request, please. And then
the question I have is um I know that
the Bible speaks of not uh consulting
mediums or spirits, you know, any kind
of spiritualism kind of stuff like that.
But um I've noticed that in forensic
science, sometimes when they can't solve
a cold case file, they have been
resorting to mediums or people that call
themselves psychics, and I was wanting
to know what you what you have to say
about that uh considering what the Bible
also says, of course.
Yeah, well, there's several passages in
the Bible where it speaks in very strong
terms against mediums, astrologers,
witches, those who have familiar spirits
that consult the dead.
And um all this kind of witchcraft and
wizardry is forbidden by the Lord. You
know, if God gives a prophet some kind
of supernatural power, it's just right
up front. It's not working with the
diabolical arts of the dark side.
Um Well, we got a number of verses
referencing that. I'm just looking at
one in Leviticus chapter 19 verse 31
that says, "Give no regard to mediums or
familiar spirits. Do not seek after them
to be defiled by them." So, the Bible's
quite clear. If we're seeking guidance
and we're seeking advice, the one to go
to would be God.
He's the one that can direct the
Christian. Uh we shouldn't be seeking
guidance from mediums or here the Bible
says familiar spirits, those who consult
the dead.
But yet in real life these people are
solving, you know, murder cases. Is that
insignificant that they're helping out
in a way?
All right. So, the question is what
about, you know, some of these folks
that are supposedly consulting with uh
the police departments and helping them
solve cases, whether they're murders,
missing person, burglary.
And we've probably heard about those
things before.
That doesn't mean it's the power of God.
Um even back in the days of the
disciples in the book of Acts, it talks
about a magician
who the people gave a lot of attention
to. I think this is like Acts 9 or
might be 10. Simon.
And um
they thought he had the great power of
God.
And it was actually the power of the
devil cuz the devil, you know, let's
suppose the devil inspires somebody to
kidnap someone.
Well, the devil then can tell a psychic
where that person's hidden. So, the
devil's got that information. He can
pass it on and then leave everyone
thinking that the psychic has got great
spiritual power from God.
Well, he may have spiritual power, but
it's not from God.
Yeah, that passage in Acts is actually
in Acts chapter 8. Talks about Simon who
practiced sorcery and had quite a
following there in the area of Samaria.
And when he saw the disciples performing
miracles, he wanted to do the same
thing.
He wanted to buy the Holy Spirit.
Yeah, and Peter had some pretty strong
words for him for for attempting that.
So, just because a person and the witch
of Endor, you know, Saul went and saw a
witch.
He killed himself the next day. And the
Bible says because he consulted a woman
with a familiar spirit. So, God's pretty
clear. He does not want his people
uh using these dark arts
um for information.
And of course, the Bible says the devil
is very powerful.
He's the highest level of the angels
prior to the fall, and so he he's able
to deceive. The Bible speaks of him
being a deceiver from the beginning.
He's going to deceive people any way he
can. Yep. And we have a lesson
specifically dealing with does God
inspire psychics and astrologers, and we
will send you Patricia a free copy if
you just call the resource line. The
number to call is 800-835-6747.
You can ask for the study guide called
Does God Inspire Astrologers and
Psychics? We'd be happy to send this to
you, Patricia, or anybody who calls and
asks. That number again is 800-835-6747.
And the phone line here at the studio in
Sacramento, California is 800-463-
7297.
800-463-7297.
Next caller that we have waiting on line
is Eric, listening from Canada. Eric,
welcome to the program.
Eric, are you there?
You might have the mute on. Eric,
listening
on satellite from Canada. One more time.
Eric.
There we are. Eric, you there?
Hi there. Hey, sorry.
And your question tonight?
Uh I was just wondering why you teach
the same doctrine as the
Roman Catholic Church with Good Friday
and Easter.
But tell me what's your What What do you
mean by that?
Well,
you guys all seem to think that God
doesn't know how to count 3 days and 3
nights.
Are you saying that you think that Jesus
did not die on Friday?
No, he didn't die on Friday. And is your
reason because Matthew chapter 12 it
says as Jonah was in the belly of the
fish 3 days and 3 nights of the son of
man will be in the heart of the earth 3
days and 3 nights?
That's right.
Can you show me where in the Bible it
says the heart of the earth is the tomb?
Hell is uh
is the grave. But where in the Bible
does it call the heart of the earth the
tomb?
Well, I I'm not proficient in Hebrews.
Well, all right. Let me Let me just give
you a something to think about because a
lot of people I think make that mistake.
The verse you're talking about appears
one time in the Bible
and it's in Matthew chapter 12. And
Jesus said as Jonah was in the belly of
the whale 3 days and 3 nights, so the
son of man will be in the heart of the
earth 3 days and 3 nights. And you're
right, it is 3 days and 3 nights.
Jesus was betrayed Thursday night. He
began to suffer for our sins
Thursday night.
Thursday night, Friday night, Saturday
night Christ was paying the penalty for
sin. He was in the heart of the earth,
that means in the clutches of the world.
The devil was punishing him. He was
experiencing Matter of fact, when Jesus
was arrested Thursday night, he said,
"Now is the hour of darkness." So you
can start calculating.
And
that's why it starts Thursday night,
Friday night, Saturday night. He rose
Sunday.
And the Bible's pretty clear. Tells us
that it was the preparation day when
Jesus was crucified, which is what the
Jews call Friday. And of course Jesus
referred to the devil as the prince of
this earth.
When it talks about Jesus being in the
heart of the earth, that was the time
when Christ voluntarily
allowed himself to come under the
control of the power of evil. Of course,
Jesus resisted. He never sinned, but he
was separated from the Father as we have
the account in the Garden of Gethsemane.
So the heart of the earth was just a
time of of trial, a time of testing for
Jesus.
Uh the suffering of Christ was not just
on the cross. The suffering started
earlier Thursday evening there in the
upper room with the disciples and then
mount the Garden of Gethsemane. Two very
significant things happened Thursday. He
had the Last Supper.
And then he prayed in the garden, "Not
my will, thy will be done." Three times
he began to shed blood. His blood didn't
just start falling on the cross. He
began shedding blood Thursday night. Not
only when he sweat and prayed, he
perspired blood.
They beat him and he bled. And then he
bled on the cross. So that was Thursday
night and he suffered Thursday, Friday,
Saturday. Rose Sunday.
And we have a book we'll send you on
that that I think you'll enjoy, Eric.
It's a good question. It's called The
Sign of Jonah. The Sign of Jonah. The
number to call is 800-835-6747.
You can ask for the book called The Sign
of Jonah that actually looks at this
passage of scripture and looks at some
of the other verses in the Bible to help
explain this.
We'll be happy to send that to anybody
who calls and asks. That number is
800-835-6747.
Ask for the book called The Sign of
Jonah. You can also read the book for
free online at the Amazing Facts
website. Just type in there The Sign of
Jonah.
Our next caller is Alex, listening from
Michigan. Alex, we have just a few more
minutes before our break.
Hi guys. Real quick question for you.
Okay. Yeah. Um
I learned tonight that uh somebody who
committed adultery
um
and gets divorced is not to remarry,
that that's the command of the Lord as
far as
they they can never get remarried. Now,
I am remarried. Okay, that was my
situation. I was I won't go into a bunch
of long details. I was married for 26
years.
It was a very dysfunctional marriage. I
broke down.
I walked out of the marriage. I was very
distraught
uh from a lot of things that I was
dealing with.
So anyway,
um
I since went back to my ex-wife a long
time ago. I asked her, "Hey, you know, I
ask you to forgive me." She said, "Hey,
I forgive you." And
she asked me to forgive her for a lot of
her failures and I told her I forgive
her.
And um
before I went there
and I asked her
um
I asked the Lord, "Do you want me to go
back to my marriage? Do you want me to
be reconciled?"
And he said, "No, I don't want you to go
back to that marriage." And he said,
"I'll show you." Because I was in a lot
of turmoil over it.
So I went back to talk to my wife and we
asked each other for forgiveness and
then we got into a really really bad
fight.
And I said, "Man, I said, Lord, you are
really showing me that you know, you do
not want me to come back to this
marriage." So I I I dropped it and I
said, "Okay, Lord, I believe that you've
forgiven me. You know, I
I think you
got to turn this into a question before
we run out of time. So
Okay. So a person that committed
adultery and is divorced
uh according to the scripture, they're
not allowed to get remarried, but I've
remarried. So what am I supposed to do?
Well, there's a lot of people that sin
and it doesn't mean it's the
unpardonable sin.
Uh you know, Jesus tells us pretty
clearly a man shall leave his father and
mother, cleave to his wife.
Uh they'll be one flesh and he says what
God has joined together, let not man put
asunder. So we're supposed to recognize
marriage as a sacred divine covenant.
Now, a lot of people fail
and a lot of people sin.
Is it the unpardonable sin? No.
Um you have David in the Bible who
committed adultery and married someone
he shouldn't have married, which was
Bathsheba.
And he was punished for that. He
suffered. But God forgave him
and later accepted Bathsheba as his
wife.
But there were consequences.
Um and so, you know, a lot of people I I
can't change what the Bible says. These
are the words of Jesus. You're going to
find in Matthew chapter 5 verse You just
read Matthew 5:27 to 30 and it's all
pretty clear.
But um
I have a book I'll send you a free copy
of, Alec, that I Alec, I think you'll
appreciate. And it's called Marriage,
Divorce, and Remarriage. It's a free
book. It has not just this verse.
It's got all the verses. It talks
specifically about your question. It's
an important question. I want you to
understand what the Bible says. Don't
lose hope. When Jesus met the Samaritan
woman, she said, "I've
I've had five husbands." Or actually
Jesus said, "You've had five husbands
and you're married to someone now or
living with someone now you're not
married to." And still he accepted her
and forgave her sins and she started
working for him. So, you know, God meets
us where we're at. You cannot always
unscramble scrambled eggs. And we
appreciate your call. Ask for the free
book. The number is 800-835-6747.
And the book is called Marriage,
Divorce, and Remarriage. Call that
number, we'll send you a free copy. And
we thank you for your call. Listening,
friends, we're not going away. We're
just going to take a brief break. Going
to get a drink of water, catch our
breath. And we do have lines open. Call
with your questions. 800-463-7297.
We're coming back.
Stay tuned. Bible Answers Live will
return in a moment.
I really wanted to start a new
devotional habit, but life got in the
way. Next thing I know, we're a month
into the new year and I'm like, "What's
the point of starting?" Then I saw 365
Amazing Answers to Big Bible Questions.
Each day is a single study. So you can
start anywhere on any day and not miss a
thing. They're crisp, clear, and
enlightening.
Get yours today by calling 800-538-7275
or visit afbookstore.com.
Amazing Facts, through your faithful
support, has had a major impact on some
of the largest non-Christian locations
in the world. Beyond the Great Wall, the
printing and translation of our books
and video materials are in constant
motion.
The Amazing Facts Chinese language
website is now one of our most visited
websites.
We also translated thousands of pieces
of literature for these nations. What
started out as hundreds of followers is
now in the hundreds of thousands. The
impact of your funds invested in sharing
the everlasting gospel in these foreign
lands will be felt for years to come.
You know, every week we hear the most
incredible stories from all over the
globe of lives that are being changed
and hearts that are being transformed by
the power of the word. And none of it
could happen without your teamwork with
this ministry. God bless you.
Every Bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life.
So, what are you waiting for? Get the
answers you need for a fuller, richer,
more confident life.
You're listening to Bible Answers Live.
This broadcast is a previously recorded
episode. If you'd like answers to your
Bible-related questions on the air,
please call us next Sunday between 7:00
p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific time. To
receive any of the Bible resources
mentioned in this evening's program,
call 800-835-6747.
Once again, that's 800-835-6747.
Now, let's join pastors Doug Batchelor
and Jean Ross for more Bible Answers
Live.
Hello, listening friends. Bible Answers
Live back for the second half. If you
tuned in along the way, we are, as you
can tell from the title,
a live Bible answer program. And we
invite you to call in with your
questions. We have uh the numbers lines
open. Here's the number, 800-463-7297.
If you call and it rings a little bit,
he that endures to the end will get on
the air. Just let it ring and someone
will get your call. 800-463-7297.
I am Doug Batchelor.
My name is Jean Ross, and we're ready to
go right back to the phone lines. We
have Joshua listening from Michigan.
Joshua, you're on the air.
Hello.
Get close to your phone, Joshua. You're
in Michigan and we're in California. Hi.
Um
I have a question. Can you hear me all
right? Yeah, you on speakerphone? Yeah.
Is there a way to get on the
old-fashioned version where you pick it
up? Yeah, I got old-fashioned.
Oh, that's a whole lot better. Thank
you.
All right. Sorry about that. Um
so, my question is more of just uh
um thinking out loud. So, I was
listening to the program about
Armageddon and
um it was very fascinating and there's a
lot of conversation about that. Um but
my I'm thinking,
you know,
how important it is for us to love God
with all of our heart, our soul, and our
mind, and our strength.
And um to love our neighbor as
ourselves. And those are the two
greatest commands, and only three things
last forever, faith, hope, and love, and
the greatest of these is love.
Um but still there's like there's things
that are going on um
in like the end times,
you know,
are a thing. So, are you wondering
happened yet. What the How how to how to
how to resurrect the two, you know,
loving others, but also being aware of
the end times. Yeah.
Well, you're you're
wise in asking that question because
I know people that become so preoccupied
with the when and how of Jesus coming
that they forget the most important
thing is
uh no matter what happens in the world,
we're to be nurturing our relationship
with the Lord where we love the Lord
with all our heart. Whatever
circumstances come, whatever tests we
face, we want to be a a witness for God.
So, that's got to be the priority. Uh
you know, we all have heard about people
who see what's going on in the world,
and their response is,
you know, run to the hills and get
survival gear and food that'll last
buried underground for 20 years,
and that's somehow going to save you.
Um
if you don't have a loving relationship
with the Lord, none of that's going to
save you.
So,
yeah, seek first, Jesus said, the
kingdom of God, his righteousness, and
all the other things, they'll take care
of themselves.
Amen.
So, but yeah, the reason we do talk
about the signs of the times and
prophecies
is to stir people
so they'll say, "Hey,
I I better get my life together because
the world may not last forever.
And these are serious times, and I need
to be ready."
These are the times that try men's
souls, someone wrote.
And uh you know, people that
world's
wrapping up, and they're just they're
seeking after the world and the things
of the world, and they need to be
seeking after God. So, that's why we let
people know, be aware of the times.
Yeah, that's what Christ said when when
he was in his ministry, he said,
uh wait, what was that? Do you do you
recall the exact phrase that he said?
begin to happen, lift up your eyes. And
uh Yeah. pray always that you might
escape all these things and stand before
the Son of Man. So, he wants us to keep
the priority of seeking first his
kingdom.
Hey, well, Joshua, we'll be we'll be
happy to send you that book we're
offering tonight. It's actually a
booklet that's easy reading, very
interesting, called Armageddon.
And uh just call the resource number,
and we'll send that to you. And the
number to call is 800-835-6747.
You can ask for the book called
Armageddon. We'll be we'll be happy to
send it to anybody who calls and asks.
Our next caller that we have is Grace
listening from Washington. Grace,
welcome to Bible Answers Live.
Hello, everyone.
Hi, how are you doing?
Oh, I'm doing good. Um thank you for
taking my question. Um
so, I I was wondering uh
I never know if I'm saved. Um I always
struggle with feeling like I have to do
certain things
to be saved, and I know that's not how
it works cuz I know no matter what I do,
I'll never be good enough to be saved,
but I don't know, just
I don't really know how you can tell. I
don't want to, you know, be
presumptuous, but I don't want to, you
know, be afraid all the time, either.
Well, that's a good question. A lot of
people battle with what you're
describing there.
Um
and I need to give you an honest answer.
There's a lot of misinformation that
circulates among Christians.
Uh
because some people become so
works-oriented, pastors have swung the
pendulum to the other side, and they
say, "There's nothing you can do to be
saved." Well, that's patently not true.
What separates the saved from the lost
is indeed something that the saved do.
You need to believe. You need to come to
Jesus. And you draw near to God, and he
will draw near to you. Uh for the
prodigal son to be forgiven, he had to
get up and come home.
And then you see what I mean, there is
something you need to do.
Um it's it it's based on faith, but you
know, Christ said, "Repent, for the
kingdom of heaven is at hand." We need
to tell the Lord we are sorry for our
sins,
confess to the Lord and repent of our
sins, and he promises if we
uh confess our sins, he is faithful and
just to forgive us our sins and to
cleanse us from all unrighteousness.
But then as we receive the Lord, we're
to walk in the Lord. And that may be the
part that you wonder, am I ever walking
well enough?
Right.
I think that I think the very term saved
confuses people. Saved makes it sound
like
you've arrived.
Um
when you come to the Lord, you come just
like you are, like the song says, "Just
as I am."
God accepts you based on faith. You
come, you repent, you confess, you
believe,
and he receives you, and all your sins
are cast into the depths of the sea.
Then begins sanctification.
Justification is when you come to the
Lord just like you are.
Sanctification is now the process of
walking with the Lord,
and you're not to walk in fear. How many
times did Jesus say don't be afraid?
If you love the Lord,
you need to have faith that if you
really love him and you are doing what
you can to try to please him because you
love him, not to be saved, that um he
will finish the work he's begun in your
life.
The Bible calls him the author and the
finisher of our faith. Believe that the
Lord is not going to try to catch you
when you've made a mistake and take you
out. Believe that he is going to
continue to work in your life as you
trust him to transform you. Cuz being a
Christian is a conversion. It means old
things are passed away, all things are
made new. We become new creatures. Isn't
that right?
Yes. So, if you if you
Thank you very much.
Yeah, if you see that you're you're
struggling to grow, don't be
discouraged. Draw closer to the Lord.
Focus on the Lord. We become like what
we look at. And if you're looking at
Jesus, you will become like him. We'd
like to send you a book that I think
will give you some peace. It's called
Three Steps to Heaven.
Three Steps to Heaven. And uh it's a
simple book, but it's I think it'll
really help you to find confidence in
your relationship with the Lord. Would
you like that?
Oh, yes, please.
Free. Just call the number Pastor Ross
is going to give you.
The number is 800-835-6747.
And ask for the book called Three Steps
to Heaven. We'll be happy to send it to
you, Grace, or to anybody who calls and
asks.
And again, I want to remind you that all
of the resources that we talk about here
on the program are also available at the
AmazingFacts.org.
Our next caller is Phil listening from
Toronto, Canada.
Phil, welcome to Bible Answers Live.
I have two questions.
First, um
um birth defects through inbreeding, are
they related to the fall in the garden?
Are they a product of the fall in the
garden? And second question, the lady
asked about or for us to pray for the
gentleman who is homeless. Would she not
uh or would it not be her obligation to
take that gentleman in, knowing that
he's in need of a place to stay?
I'll take your call or uh listen to your
answer off the air. Thank you. Thank
you, Phil. Two questions. First question
was about um
inbreeding. And did it cause the fall?
No, I don't believe that. The fall was
caused because Adam and Eve did not
believe
the Lord when he said, "Don't eat from
the forbidden tree."
And um I'm sure that the fall
contributed to the problems from
intermarriage.
Um
and uh you know, maybe if the world if
there had never been sin, well, I'm
quite quite sure there wouldn't have
been any genetic mutations if there had
never been sin in the world, just like
there were no thorns or thistles or any
problems with creation until sin.
Uh your second question, if you know a
homeless person that needs help, is a
Christian obligated to take them in?
No.
Um
you know, the Bible does say, you know,
I was hungry and you brought me food. I
was thirsty, you gave me drink. I was a
stranger and you took me in.
But not every family, you know, I know
some single mothers and they got
children and it's certainly not
appropriate to bring a homeless man in
the house and you might just not have
the resources and space. You might be
living in, you know, uh a city where
there's, you know, 500 homeless people
on your way to work. You can't
practically bring all them into your
home.
But you probably make a good point,
Phil, that
Christians don't do as much of that. I I
don't even do it as much. I used to pick
up hitchhikers and bring them home. Wife
would go, "Oh, okay."
You know,
and um
but um you know, sometimes in the is
there's safety issues. Sometimes the
people
they have drug problems today and you've
got family with children. You just got
to be wise. Sometimes the Holy Spirit
will say, "This is a person who's
you know, will really benefit from
that."
And it is a valid question.
Anyway, thank you for your questions,
Phil, and that does open another line.
If you have a Bible question, we still
have about 20 minutes left.
800-463-7297.
Pick up your phone now. Who's next?
We've got Christy Joe listening from
Montana. Christy, welcome to the
program.
Hi, thank you for taking my call.
Hi, Christy. I've been to Missoula.
Hello.
Hey, hello. My question is more of like
an an advice thing. Um the Mormons are
sending their
um
their missionaries out constantly. I
guess the Mormons are now coming to
Montana. Anyway, I don't believe that
they are a Christian faith and I would
just like to have a couple of
scriptures that I could pull out that
are just concrete just to um arm myself
because they've done a lot of studying,
a lot of preparing to go on these
missions to come to your door and they
always catch me a little off guard. So,
I just was hoping that you could give me
a just a few scriptures I could pull out
and say, "I don't believe that the
Mormon faith is the true faith and this
is why."
All right, well, very good. Um
well, first of all, at the at the core
of and and I want to be careful. You
know, I've met just some lovely Mormon
people. They're lovely people. They love
their families.
Absolutely. Their theology, I do think
is a cultish theology.
And so, I want to separate the two. So,
I I know just some tremendous Mormon
people. They have very high ethics.
They're very honest, very hard working,
close families.
But you know, in their theology, when
you study it, they basically believe our
God is not the final God, that our God,
you know, once was a lower kind of God
and worked his way up and ended up
getting, you know, a galaxy or his own
dominion and that someday we will be
gods. But this was what God said to Adam
and Eve or the devil actually told Adam
and Eve that
if you eat the forbidden fruit, you will
be as God.
And there was someone put out a video a
few years ago called The God Makers.
It's probably dated now, but
uh it talks about a number of the
teachings of Mormonism, that being one.
Then this is a question I ask is I say,
"Is God growing
and becoming greater?" And they say,
"Yeah."
I say, "Well, does God know everything?"
And if he knows everything, how can you
learn something if you know everything?
So, the very idea that God is somehow
expanding and becoming a bigger God,
um you just can't support that. The
Bible says, "There is I am the Lord and
there is no other."
And that's in Isaiah. You can make
Pastor Ross is going to look that up.
There is no other God.
Um so, the idea there are other gods out
there in the cosmos of their galaxies or
or universes,
um that I think is a foundational
problem. Yeah, the verse you're looking
at Isaiah chapter 45 verse 5 and it
says, "I am the Lord, there is no other.
There is no God besides me."
And then also the the idea in their
teachings that um
Jesus is not a God eternal God. They
create They think Jesus and Lucifer
somehow brothers at one point.
And you know, they came to the world and
nothing could be further from the truth.
Christ is the creator. All things that
were made were made by him. You can read
John chapter 1.
And the devil is a creation. Lucifer was
a created angel that fell.
And so, they were not brothers.
And so, there's just some real
foundational problems and when you have
a a foundation that's crooked,
everything else in theology starts to
get crooked. You know, Isaiah chapter 8
verse 20 says, "To the law and to the
testimony, if they speak not according
to this word, it is because there is no
light in them." So, the law, which when
we talk about the law, we're talking
about the first five books of Moses,
that's what the Jews understood as the
law. The testimony would be everything
else that the prophets wrote.
If uh what a person says or what a
person teaches contradicts
the law of God, contradicts what the
scriptures have said, well, the Bible's
pretty clear, there's no light in them.
Yeah, I studied with Mormons several
times and uh
when I I catch them on a scripture they
can't answer, they say, "Yeah, but the
Book of Mormon or The Pearl of Great
Price." And they quote some other
extra-biblical book by Joseph Smith.
And if it conflicts with the Bible, and
they say, "Oh, this is fresh
information. The Bible's older."
Uh and of course, just having a whole
'nother Bible
that they say was written by the 10
tribes that came to America. We know
from DNA now that 10 tribes, the
American Indians are not from Israel.
And so, that just the whole thing was
based on a myth that's caused a lot of
problems.
Right.
So, yeah, just you can look up that book
or the video, The God Makers. I bet the
YouTube is online for free today.
Okay. Hey, thank you very much and
there'll be a lot of scriptures there. I
appreciate that, Christy Joe.
Next uh caller is Rick from Fort
Lauderdale in Florida. Uh Rick, welcome
to the program.
Hey, thank you, pastors, and I loved
your show on Facebook, all your shows on
Facebook. It's really uh very good. Hey,
I had a question about Revelation. It
mentions wormwood.
What is wormwood? Is that like a meteor
or
Well, you know, some have said that. I
think the word Chernobyl in Russian,
someone told me it translates wormwood
and wormwood was a bitter herb.
And um
but in Revelation,
Pastor Ross might address it because he
does seminars in Revelation. Yeah, you
know, the word wormwood first finds its
origin all the way back in Deuteronomy
29 verse 18 and literally it means um
bitterness. So, there was some kind of a
root that was rather bitter and uh you
have the story of how the water turned
to wormwood, meaning it was bitter.
People couldn't drink it.
And in Revelation, that symbol is used.
It's referencing a star called wormwood,
meaning bringing bitterness. In the
Bible, water represents the truth,
represents life. So, there is a
corruption of the truth and it's
referring to a time period where false
doctrines were introduced that corrupted
the truth of the gospel that originally
was preached by the apostles. So, it's a
counterfeit doctrine, a counterfeit
teaching.
And the word literally just means
bitterness. It's a kind of connected
with a type of bitter root. You know,
people when the Israelites were crossing
the desert and they were dying of thirst
and they ran into a pool of water and
they couldn't drink it cuz the waters
were bad.
Pastor Ross and I were camping out in
Nevada desert and there was a spring out
there and it had a sign. It said, "Can't
drink from this spring. It'll It killed
the cows when they came across."
And how disappointed they were. Well,
that's what happened to the living
water. We're polluted by great apostasy
in the church during the Dark Ages and
that's why you find that phrase
wormwood. Some people wondered if
Chernobyl if that was describing what
happened there and I I don't think
that's what that is a fulfillment of.
You know, just to be real frank with
you, there's a number of scholars,
especially in in during the early
Reformation time period, that identified
this wormwood uh that you read about in
Revelation chapter 8 verse 11 as being
the rise of Islam
and its expansion during the Ottoman
Empire. Kind of interesting study there.
It's referencing the uh the fifth
trumpet, fifth and sixth trumpet. Now,
what can we Anything we can send Rick on
that or You know, I don't think we have
a book specifically on What if he looked
up You know, you could probably look up
online, Rick. There is a book that's
public domain by Uriah Smith. It's
called Daniel and the Revelation. I've
seen it. It's free online.
you preached a sermon series not too
long ago called Islam and Christianity.
and Prophecy. Yeah. Yeah, they can go to
Amazing Facts and order that. Islam,
Christianity and Prophecy.
Thank you for your call, Rick.
Appreciate it. Next caller is Tanya
listening from Michigan. Tanya, welcome
to the program.
Um hi, how are you doing? Good. Thank
you for your call and your question. Um
I have a friend who's a Christian and I
have a person who is a Muslim. Now, this
person
um who's a Christian wants to uh wants
to go against the Bible, be evenly
unyoked and go Muslim.
Now, he wants me to accept
and turn my back on the Lord, which of
course I'm not going to do.
But
now, I know that it's right to
forgive and all that sort of thing, but
just because you forgive, does that mean
that you have to let the person in your
life even if you disagree or would that
be turning your back on the Lord? Well,
there's a it depends. You know, there
are people that we want to maintain a
relationship with so that we can
influence them in a positive way. If
someone has turned from Christianity and
they're trying to convert you,
well, then, you know, he it's like you
said, "Can two walk together if they're
not agreed?" It's really hard to be
friends with somebody
that um on an intimate level. I mean,
you can be casual acquaintances. You may
work in an office with people
Well, not
just casual.
Yeah, you know, people work together in
offices that have all different kinds of
religious backgrounds and you can be
polite and friendly and have lunch with
them, but you start becoming a close
friend with somebody that's trying to
pull you from your beliefs.
And that's not good. And um
Well, I really don't want to continue
this friendship, but he basically wants
me to oh, just accept it. I'm like, "No,
I can't do that." No, well, yeah, you
got to put the Lord first and and they
need to know where your boundaries are
and you just say, you know, as much as I
might care about you as a person, uh God
is first in my life and you know, Jesus
said, "If you got a hand, a foot, or an
eye that is offending you, even though
they're very close, cut it off."
Yeah, sometimes we have to cut off close
relationships that are dragging us down.
Right. That's what I told him and he
just yelled at me and he just like, you
know, turned a deaf ear. Doesn't sound
like a good friend and you're going to
be losing much anyway, Tanya, if they're
yelling at you.
Yeah, you know, if
if you have to turn away from somebody
because they're dragging you down,
uh you know,
Bible tells us we kind of become like
our friends.
And so, you want to pick wise friends.
It says, "He who would be wise is going
to have wise friends."
And if you want to be a strong
Christian, find strong Christian
friends. Now, that doesn't mean you
don't associate with non-believers or
you can never witness.
But uh there's a difference there.
Thank you very much for your question,
Tanya. We're going to try and squeeze in
a couple more calls. We've got Ben
listening in Iowa. Ben, welcome to the
program.
Excuse me, pastor. Uh thank you for your
program and thank you for watching. You
I'm really enjoy it. Uh if a does it a
marriage by a pastor to perform the
ceremony for people to be married or can
two people that make commitment to each
other and live with each other for a
number years be married? Uh Well, you
want to be legally married as opposed to
illegally married because the Bible does
say we should obey the laws of the land.
And if someone says, "Are you married?"
you want to be able to say yes,
definitively.
Uh you don't want to tell the state,
"No, we're not married." for tax reasons
and then tell everyone else, "Yes, we
are married." cuz then you're you're not
being honest.
So,
um what would be Why would a Christian
not want to be legally married where you
you don't have to have a pastor done it.
You can have a justice of the peace.
It'd be nice to have it done with a
church and a pastor because then you're
doing the covenant in a religious
context.
Or would you have a problem with that or
are you asking on behalf of someone else
or you're just curious?
Uh I'm asking because uh I have a
daughter that's lived with a man for 27
years and uh they've never had a
marriage before a minister, but they are
they don't
they don't claim to be married, but yet
they've been together for over 20 years.
Now, you know, I don't want to meddle in
their lives, but I wonder what prevents
them from getting married.
Um at in the beginning, uh if he got
married, they were going to take the
family farm away from him.
Uh so, for financial reasons,
they're not getting married.
So, you know,
I think that you need to do the right
thing because it is the right thing
regardless of the consequences. And if a
man and woman are going to live together
and enjoy the intimacy of marriage, they
should make the covenant in the presence
of God and it should be recognized in
our society.
Uh obviously, if two people are married,
you want those around to know you're
committed so they're not, you know,
making passes at you you and your
spouse.
But um
uh yeah.
They You know what? I've got a book. You
might want to send them a copy. We'll
send you one for free. You can give it
to him, Ben.
It's called Marriage, Divorce, and
Remarriage. We talked about earlier
tonight.
And we'll just call the number.
The number is 800-835-6747.
You can ask for the book called
Marriage, Divorce, and Remarriage. And
we have uh Donna listening from Texas.
Donna, welcome to the program.
Yes, my question is did
Judas have a choice in the betrayal of
Jesus?
Yes, he did. There were Now, because God
knew what Judas was going to do, doesn't
mean that God made him do it.
God just knew what Judas was going to
choose.
God knows everything, doesn't he?
So, we can still have a choice
and because God knows what we're going
to choose doesn't mean he's making us
choose. The prophecy said that Jesus
would be betrayed by a friend.
Judas didn't do it because the prophecy
said it. Judas The prophecy said it
because they knew what Judas was going
to choose.
But Judas was a free moral agent like
all the other apostles.
And um the Lord wanted Judas to be
saved. He didn't want him to be lost. He
washed his feet and he pled with him,
but Judas resisted because of his pride.
Okay, yeah.
That makes sense.
It does.
Yep, so hey, I appreciate your question.
We got 2 minutes. Can we do a question
in 2 minutes, Pastor Ross? It'll be
tight. Yes, we'll have Jay listening
from um South Dakota. Jay, we have just
2 minutes left.
Uh yes, I do. Good.
My question is on salvation.
Um
I
attended another church and if their
teaching is once saved, always saved.
Could you just maybe
clarify a little bit Let me make Yeah,
let me make a quick comment on that. Um
I do believe a Christian can live with
some confidence about the relationship
with the Lord, but the idea that once
you are saved, you've lost your freedom
to be lost is not taught in the Bible.
Salvation is a love relationship. You
cannot force love.
Uh my wife and I trust each other. We
have confidence in our relationship, but
we've not lost our freedom to turn from
each other.
So, there are several examples in the
Bible of people who were saved that lost
their salvation because they turned from
the Lord. Now, those who believe in once
saved, always saved, they say, "Well,
they never were saved." That's sort of
their their escape clause.
But you got King Saul, chosen by God,
filled with the Holy Spirit, even
prophesied, but through his pride, he
grieved away the spirit, took his own
life. Balaam the prophet was a prophet
of God. Through covetousness,
he lost his gift. Judas sincerely
followed the Lord. He even went out with
the other apostles casting out devils
and preaching.
But he would not give up his pride and
his covetousness and his light went out.
Jesus says in Revelation, "Repent or I
will remove your candlestick out of its
place." So, and these are messages to
churches.
He said, "Unless they repent, they're
going to lose out." So, there's
Yeah, we got a book on this. Yeah,
matter of fact, the book is called Can a
Saved Man Choose to Be Lost? Yeah, just
send for that, Jay. We'll send it to you
free. The number 800-835-6747.
Can a Saved Man Choose to Be Lost?
Friends, we are out of time for the
question part. Still have some important
announcements to come. Final appeal from
Pastor Ross and I. If you enjoy the
program, we're here because people like
you. Go online. Keep us on the air with
a donation. God bless.
Thank you for listening to today's
broadcast. We hope you understand your
Bible even better than before.
Bible Answers Live is produced by
Amazing Facts, a faith-based ministry
located in Sacramento, California.
Life's a curious thing. I mean, just
when things seem under control, wham,
you're hit with something new.
Your marriage is good. Suddenly, it's on
the brink of divorce.
That job's great.
And then it's gone. And so is your life
savings.
You feel healthy, then your doctor gives
the bad news.
What's coming next?
You could look to the stars, but they
don't have the answers.
But this does.
The Prophecy Study Bible by Amazing
Facts.
This Bible special, it's 27 personal
study guides lead you on a life-changing
journey through God's word
to discover real answers to life's
questions. From health and relationships
to family and the future.
The hope's in here.
Get your Amazing Facts Prophecy Study
Bible today by calling 800-538-7275
or visit afbookstore.com.
Did you know that Noah was present at
the birth of Abraham?
Okay, maybe he wasn't in the room,
but he was alive and probably telling
stories about his floating zoo.
From the creation of the world to the
last day events of Revelation,
biblehistory.com
is a free resource where you can explore
major Bible events and characters,
enhance your knowledge of the Bible, and
draw closer to God's word. Go deeper.
Visit the Amazing Bible Timeline at
biblehistory.com.
If you'd like to enhance your study of
God's word, visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org sign up for our
free Bible study course. And make sure
to check out our online bookstore at
afbookstore.com,
which offers thousands of inspiring
books, DVDs, and more to help you get
the most out of God's word. To take
advantage of the offers you've heard on
this broadcast, call us at 800-835-6747
or visit our website at
amazingfacts.org.
Did you enjoy this program? Make sure to
tell your family and friends. Tune in
next time for more Bible answers live.
Honest and accurate answers to your
Bible questions.